what is going on everybody welcome to
these seconds data analysis with Python
and pandas tutorial video in this video
what we're going to be talking about is
going over the pans basics so you've
seen your first pandas dataframe and
what we're doing with it but now we're
actually going to code it ourselves and
go through with it so if you didn't copy
and paste the code from before basically
what we're going to have is you can copy
and paste that code and then we'll just
start with an empty slate here and we
don't need i/o data either okay so we're
going to use basically these four lines
here pandas as PD again PD is just kind
of shorthand it's a standard if you're
going to share your code or ask somebody
to help you with your code you probably
should use standards matplotlib pipe
lattes PLT standard matplotlib import
style that's so we can quickly make our
graph look a little more appealing than
the default so the first thing that
we're going to go ahead and do is like
let's say so pandas dataframe if you're
coming from Python and data frame just
isn't sitting right with you for
whatever reason a data frame is a lot
like a Python dictionary in its heart
and the way that we can reference it is
like a Python dictionary at its heart so
first of all let's say you're you're
operating website now eventually we'll
get into housing data and stuff like
this but for now we'll just use a really
basic example let's say you've got a
website you got some web I was thinking
stats and I type data and then I either
one was fine anyway yeah some say you've
got some information here let's say the
first bit of information is the day so
de colon and then we'll have an a list
here this will be day 1 2 3 4 5 and 6
and then after that maybe you've got
visitors and also again if you're not
familiar with dictionaries I have the
basics tutorial on dictionaries
relatively easy to understand it if you
just go visit that tutorial real quick
visitors we're not a very popular
website so we don't really have that
many visitors
see 64 34 I think that's six right yep
six then finally a bounce rate so this
is the rate of how many people will come
to you a landing page and leave
immediately not something you want 65 70
to 60 to 64 and 54 and that's not six so
one month sixty six awesome okay so
that's actually probably industry
average so 65 percent of people that
come to your website leave immediately
shocking I know
now the next thing is to convert this to
a data frame now it's not always going
to be this simple but with the
dictionary it is because the dictionary
just suits a data frame really easily so
we can say DF equals PD that's
referencing pandas now where I say
pandas dataframe note the caps capital D
capital F there and then web stats boom
we have created ourselves a data frame
now when you're working with pandas and
you do changes or you make something a
data frame whatever you know just
writing it out I'm confident you know
that made a data frame but I can't see
it that's why people love gooeys and
that's why people like Excel over
programming because with Excel they can
visually see it well with myth pandas
you can visually see it too so what you
can do is you can say print you could
print the entire data frame so DF and
again DF is just used as shorthand it's
a standard generally if you make a data
frame you call it DF but that's not rich
that's like the least restrictive of all
of these standards if if you want to
call your data frame something else like
before we called it I think exo-m it was
it was more it at least it made sense to
have that variable name so especially if
you're going to have like five data
frames it would it would be very unclear
even if you call them DF one two three
four five that would be really messy
it's it's better to call them something
that relates to the bed frame okay so
anyway so you can call this you know
stats or something like that but we'll
just call it data frame so you can print
out the data frame f5 to run it save
good and there we have our information
you'll notice that we've got the 0 1 2 3
4 5
here again that's the index now if you
don't specify an index everything is
treated as a normal column and an index
will just be kind of generated
automatically for you but later on we'll
be talking about in this tutorial how to
set the specific index and we'll talk
about why you would do that in a moment
now that's our entire data frame so
that's six rows now you can reference
just a specific section by doing print
DF head okay and you have two head just
prints the first five rows zero into the
four conversely we can also do D F dot
tail and that prints the last five
finally what we could do is you can do
maybe you just want to print the last
two well you can throw a 2 in there as a
parameter and this will print only the
last two columns so that would be right
here pretty cool
so you'll find yourself using df/de head
basically every time you know you apply
maybe a calculation you create a new
column based on some logic or something
like that always a good idea to just
kind of output that that data frame to
the console so you can actually see what
you're doing if you're working in most
interactive development editors you're
gonna see the data frame anyways every
time you redefine it so so that's one of
the bonuses to using like an eye Python
notebook a lot of people have been
asking me hey man you ever heard of
ipython notebook yes I have I just don't
like them very much I'm trying I want to
like them very badly I just simply tell
them anyway so that's purging out the
actual data frame so you can see what
you're doing now let's set in index why
might we have in index first of all the
index is basically what how all your
data is either related or how you want
to visualize it related so for us maybe
we want to relate the day but you know
the most obvious index for this data
would be day right so if you have any
sort of time series data generally the
index is going to be the day
but if you've got a website maybe you
would want your index to be visitors and
then you want to know you know maybe
what are the you know you've got
visitors but then you've also got bounce
rates and maybe you've got you know
referrals and stuff like this and you
want to see how everything interacts
with a certain data point like visitor
count or something like that you know
you never know what you might want to do
and you can have multiple indexes I went
I've never needed multiple indexes but
you can do it and there's a few reasons
why you might do it but it doesn't make
much reason to cover that right now so
the way that you can set in index is
just DF dot set underscore index two and
we'll say day now if I do something like
this print EF dot set index today and
run that you'll see the return is the
entire data frame with DES now being the
index but then later on we're going to
you know be epic programmers we're going
to do a bunch of calculations blah blah
blah blah blah and then we go print D F
dot head and then we're going to we see
this first one which is the way we
wanted it and then we get the second one
and it's more like what what happened
here
we lost our index all right that's
really annoying and this is something
that's going to slap you in the face a
few times at least but what happens here
is when you modify the data frame like
this what what actually is happening
here is when you say DF dot set index
day you are returned a new data frame
okay so that's why this print statement
worked out for you your your returned a
new data frame and that's going to be
the same thing if you're in an
interactive development uh like Anna uh
let's say ipython notebook you're going
to be returning the data frame it's
going to look great and you really yeah
cool and you're gonna keep going on and
then suddenly your index is no longer
well what's happening is it's just
returning a new data frame so what you
have to do is one of two things one one
way that you can handle for this is you
can create well I'm gonna leave this
code here just simply because I usually
post up the code but actually well I'm
just going to come in
um anyway one way that you can do it is
you can say something like this D F
equals D F dot set index today and then
you could print it you know D F dot hat
and that's going to work just fine okay
but that's kind of sloppy and but you
could also say like maybe you want to
make a new data frame out of it
so you could say DF - okay so they leave
that there so you can make your choice
if you want to set a new data frame so
obviously DF 2 equals that so then if
you printed DF 2 dot head you would get
the newer right so they give you the
option whether you want to keep your
original data frame or not now what if
you don't want to do this like double
you know this equals nonsense
well the other way that you can do this
is you can just say DF dot set index
today and then you can specify in place
equals true and this will modify the
data frame right then there and we can
say DF subhead run that and there you go
so that happens so uh you can try to
internalize this as much as possible I
still get slapped by this maybe you guys
are better than me but that's something
that's going to hit you if you find out
that you know these various changes
you're making just whatever reason
aren't showing up it's not just when you
set the index there's a bunch of these
commands that you're going to do and
then you're going to think it worked and
then click it on you're going to realize
then or because you didn't either set it
in place or redefine it moving on let's
make some space here to reference a
specific column so right now we only
have two columns you get de as the index
and you've got the column of visitors in
the column bounce rate to reference a
specific column it's pretty simple you
would say DF and then like it's a
dictionary square brackets and then
visitors visitors we're going to save it
and run that and there we go we got just
the columns visitors just the
information and all that now
you might actually want this to be like
a list or even an umpire right we'll
talk about that don't you worry close
this another way that you can reference
just a specific columns you can use a
as if it's like an attribute so you
could say print D F dot visitors okay so
we're get two outputs of visitors here
identical there's no difference okay so
if you'll notice up here in bounce rate
I put an underscore this allows you to
use that dot like it's an attribute if
you want if you leave a space that's
totally fine you can reference it like
this but you obviously cannot do dot
bounce space rate that would be a syntax
error right so you can't do that
okay but of course you could do you know
bounce rate actually let's just return
this you could do you could take bounce
rate with the space here copy paste save
and run that and that's totally fun you
can do that so you might find data sets
have spaces there so you won't be able
to do this kind of notation but you can
you can still handle spaces that's fine
so now the next thing that we're going
to go ahead and cover is so that's how
you can reference like a single column
if you want it now how do you reference
multiple columns if you want you can
reference the entire data frame as we've
already shown but how do you reference
multiple columns well what you can do is
you could save print DF like you're
going to reference a column only this
time we're referencing a list of columns
so - you know square brackets within
square brackets and this is a list okay
so we can say we want a reference and
I'm going to go ahead and add that under
case again because I want that there now
we can reference bounce rate visitors
visitors okay so that will print just
those columns now obviously we had other
information and so those are the only
two columns that we had but if you just
want to reference two columns that's how
you would do it finally how do we
reference how do we convert this to
maybe a list okay so what we could do is
we could say print D F dot visitors
visitors dot to list I'm going to
comment these things out right here save
and run that
and sure enough that's been converted to
a list now with Python there is no such
thing natively as an array you have
lists and then you've got
multi-dimensional lists like this within
list listen a list is totally valid but
as you will find here in just one moment
well what if we did this what if we took
this original DF that so will say print
that information dot two lists so right
those were the two columns of data what
if we tried that ah shucks we can't do
that not to list that's not gonna work
out so it has no attribute because it
adds it it's being treated like it's an
array so what we're going to have to do
instead is come up to the very top
import numpy as NP that's what the
people do and then we'll do this instead
of dot to list print NP dot o R a so
we're converting this to an array close
off everything
save and run that but a boom by bing you
have your list up here and you're right
down here now of course you could
convert this to or my right - that's
totally fine but for those of you who
are familiar with other data science
libraries numpy arrays are basically
integral ok so that's what you have to
do to convert now then that final
question would be of course you know can
you do this can you say DF 2 equals PD
done data frame and we want to convert
that current DF to save and right
wouldn't you know it there it is so
let's say you're working I don't know
with open CV and you've got things that
have been converted to pixel arrays can
you put it into a panda's data frame
you sure can so really easy input output
obviously here we just done dictionaries
and umpire arrays but we'll be talking
about how you can do you know CSV files
and stuff like that as we continue along
the series so that was a lot of
information being thrown at you in a
relatively short amount of time we're
coming up on 15 minutes so I guess not
too short but it was a lot of
information if you have any questions or
comments
concerning suggestions whatever feel
free to leave them below if this was too
fast or whatever again there is a
text-based version of this tutorial on
Python programming net I will usually
link to that specific tutorial in the
description otherwise this is a data
analysis tutorial go to Python program
net dashboard data analysis there it'll
be so anyways that's where you can go if
you're looking for more information
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time